all right Colleen yes Colleen uh where
are you from originally Port Angeles
Washington
and tell me about your family growing up
I was adopted by my grandparents because
my parents were a drug addict so I was
taken in by my grandparents when I was
18 years old my grandpa was diagnosed
with cancer he passed away and then my
grandma did from covid a couple years
ago my family pretty much broke apart
and I might have I do have kids but they
were safe with my family and so my
family me we only talked due to my kids
but besides that my family's been broken
apart since my grandparents died so I
took off went to Oregon and then from
Oregon to South Dakota with my husband
to rescue his mom from a DV situation
and would have been in Arizona by now
had I not lost my backpack on the Amtrak
train but I'm here now so you're
temporarily stuck here on Skid Row yeah
we were actually across from the Union
Station when we first arrived but the
cops came by and they told us to move so
and then we were trying to find Skid Row
the community place and when we found it
we're like we're gonna be stuck here
anyway might as well find a place to put
our tent up so that's what we had to do
let me see if I can help you get out of
here a little bit
um so your childhood how would you
describe it
is rough honestly
I was honestly hurt by my biological dad
me and him don't get along because he's
the reason my ankle was broken and I had
seizures growing up so he wasn't there
for that my mom even gave birth in a
barn an actual barn with my own sibling
and there was mental and emotional abuse
and then I was also raped and sexually
assaulted due to me being even just
Native American because I'm not supposed
to be here
so it was really hard growing up for me
and because Port Angeles is not it's
like about a five to six hour thing
drive from Seattle we always had people
coming from Seattle and it gets even
rougher up there when the people from
Seattle come into Port Angeles
I am 27 I turn 28 in just three months
you have kids I have one in heaven and
two on Earth
you lost a child
31 weeks due to a blood clot in my
uterus there was nothing they could do
about it the baby was fine the weekend
on my ultrasound and then Monday came
around the weekend at the that same
weekend and
the baby had passed away over the
weekend and there was nothing they could
do about it I'm sure
it's been hard but I'm continuing on I'm
when I get to Arizona I'll always be
able to do a proper burial for my son
and then my kids can come home and be
with me on our land so and your kids are
with your my kids are in Washington
right now they're with family once I get
to the Navajo Nation in Arizona they'll
be transferred down to me once I get
housing and everything I just got to get
to the Navajo Nation in Arizona as well
to talk to the chief in order to do so
and as far as drugs go you I smoke
marijuana I am eight years clean and
proud of it my husband's allergic to
opiates besides marijuana we smoke
cigarettes but that's it we used to used
to use I used to use Mev heroin you name
it I was always on some kind of drug no
matter what I've never tried Fentanyl
I've lost a friend due to Fenton always
is why I don't like it but I used to do
mainly meth and heroin does the pot help
you not use the heart definitely helps
me not use and helps when I have
seizures because without marijuana I
have seizures really bad I've had a
Grand Mall and when I started my CBD and
THC treatment with marijuana only I quit
having seizures I have been seizure free
for almost three years now
I have sight Twitches here and there but
that's just the after effects still from
all the pills I started taking I had 13
years old up until I was 18 because
that's what the doctor thought was best
for me but it wasn't we found out how
much pot do you smoke
I can smoke an eighth in a day if that
helps
so a lot of pot I've cleared like an
ounce in like a week so in less than a
week too depending on my stress and
whatnot
what does pot do for you at this point
pot helps me relax and focus more and it
helps me eat better because of my EDS I
have issues eating so when I'm stressed
out it's hard for me to eat so the pot
helps me sleep eat I can be able to walk
around without my EDS kicking in and
making it hard for me to walk around and
it's just I feel better and more calmer
overall
and I can actually talk to people like I
am without weed I wouldn't be able to do
this
so it's like a medicine for you it is
marijuana saved my life and I wish my
grandpa was able to have it because my
grandma was allergic to it and I know
plenty of people who have cancer that
smoke weed and even eat Edibles and it
helps their cancer but my grandpa didn't
get that choice because his wife was
allergic to marijuana so we couldn't
have any of that so when I went to go
smoke I had to go down the road where my
grandparents love to go smoke because my
grandma was not allergic to it she
couldn't have the smell at all
[Music]
are there any downsides to smoking pot
for you
besides sleeping and getting a full
thumbing now besides that now I I sleep
like a baby besides that just being here
I've just been on edge because I don't
know where I'm at all like I've never
been to California so I've been smoking
more because of that so but I'm trying
so um
does it help you with the
like the trauma you went through as a
kid oh definitely oh definitely I
because of the car accidents I don't
have a good memory and because of my
seizures I don't have a good memory so
with weed when I'm able to sit there and
think especially with reading I'm able
to actually have like my memories there
instead of when I'm completely sober I'm
just confused and I'm like
did I I did eat today right I did eat
yesterday versus when I do smoke I know
what I'm doing I can complete my tasks
better
are you supporting yourself now
I have SSDI and Native benefits but
being in California that doesn't go far
obviously because nothing here is what I
thought it was going to be so
and the train tickets oh my Lord I
didn't think for three people that would
be that much and we have my service
animal she's not here with me now
because she's been exhausted from our
journey we went from San Francisco and
we came all the way here to Los Angeles
the how'd you get here
oh SSDI I'm a native benefits and by the
luck of God I swear on that one the
trains trains and buses yeah so many
trains and buses because you have to
take one bus just go to Santa Barbara
and then get on the train to here
so
good bro
[Music]
reminds me of Saddle just a lot more
people and a lot more going on it's what
I've told my friends you know it Skid
Row LA's like Seattle it's just a whole
lot more people and a lot more going on
so if you want to come here I mean just
know don't be surprised what you see
really don't do not be surprised because
you can expect literally anything I have
encountered that being in Hawaii I've
seen more than I've needed to see it's a
beautiful place though it really is it's
gorgeous here well not here but yeah
outside of skid rows hey San Jose is
gorgeous so Santa Cruz I am thankful I
gotta go on the beach before I left
California so that was nice going into
the water
what's your biggest regret
Las Vegas regrets
probably not having someone better to
stay honestly when I was here because I
didn't realize what it was going to be
like here and not being able to say
goodbye to my grandpa or my grandma
properly
because my grandpa was my best friend
growing up and I didn't say goodbye to
him I gotta say goodbye on a phone call
and he thought he was on a highway in
Tacoma
and he instead he was on a hospital bed
so I just wish I could have saved my
goodbyes to my grandparents besides that
I just wishing I had a better plan for
when I came here to La I didn't know the
motels and stuff were going to be that
expensive if I had known that I would
have planned better but I'm only here
with SSDI native benefits I'm doing the
best I can your goal is to get to the
I'm trying to get to the Navajo Nation
in Arizona yes and that it's going to be
what kind of life for you well I get to
be with my people learn more about my
Heritage bring my kids down there to
know their Heritage as well because
they're also they're also Native
American Navajo and we get housing down
there and we get well I've been looking
for like I said the housing and
everything a place for my kids to grow
up be around their people maybe around
my people you know be involved with that
kind of community because that's what
I've always wanted was to be more
involved with my kind of people than
Native Americans because that's who I am
I'm Native American
and raise awareness too I guess you've
been to the neighborhood Nation I was
there when I was like 9 10 years old but
that was like the last time I was there
sadly
because then my parents my grandparents
quit traveling we didn't have enough
funds to travel so that was like the
last time I was there I did get to go to
the Alamo before I left so
you think what I got to go to the Alamo
that was cool I've been to the Alamo and
crazy horses yeah just yeah don't be
surprised if the Navajo Nation is not
the paradise ear yeah yeah I've been
told don't be surprised if everything's
different I'm like yeah I'm after I've
been told about La I am going to make
sure to be on point this time like
expect everything at this point I'm not
in Washington anymore so it's just
taking time to adjust
your friends
I have friends throughout the United
States here and there I actually have
one of my friends over at Venice Beach
here in California
you see the ocean
I haven't been able to see the ocean yet
since being here in La I wanted you but
my old man doesn't want to go over there
because we got to go to the Union
Station in a way we'd rather not be that
far from it so
and you're okay with this lifestyle that
you're living just I'm a javelin happy
and so once I get to the Navajo Nation
will be getting house
I'm going to continue travel because I
love traveling anyway
yeah you might just stay on the road
once my kids get on uh get old enough
and like that and stuff and I can
actually take them out traveling and
stuff and it's okay I'm gonna do that
and go show them around and stuff
because I have family in Texas and
Oklahoma I want to go see too
what's your biggest fear
honestly
just getting hurt while being here
because I don't know where I'm at the
rational fear I don't know where I'm at
I'm so lost like I have a dead phone
right now and I can't even go to the
store because I don't know where I'm at
at all like I don't want to go on I've
already been encountered by a gang I
don't want to change walking down the
block here is dangerous yeah walking
even just a block you see a whole bunch
of stuff and I just don't know where to
go
I really don't
I know where the refresh spot is for
skid row is but that's about it
and Colleen what would you say is the
most important thing you've learned in
your life
love your friends and families you never
know when their last day is going to be
and I've learned that the hard way I had
my one of my good friends taken because
he got a mix of Fentanyl and he shot up
and walked across a glass of rock and
was found in downtown Port Angeles on
the crosswalk Crossing it dead
so love everyone your friends and family
no matter if you hate them for whatever
reason just love them because you never
know when the last day is going to be
seriously
love everyone everyone has their own
demons yes but we may have our own
demons and battles but we can still love
one another that's great
thank you Colleen thank you
Arizona
trying to